haha well um you know there's a little
be a lot of hours in each day in that
room normally in a 20 24 hour period you
know you go to the gym the grocery store
you go to work you go out these people
you actually you know so many things and
all of a sudden you know it's like a
piece of paper and a pencil and yourself
you can look at it from many
perspectives like oh all you have to do
is just sit in a box you know but at the
end of the day like you're gonna be
going through a lot and you have a lot
of thought process and oh you know um
overall I think I think that I'm the
type of person that will be able to
handle it well you know I just think the
hardest part is going to be detaching
from people i talked with daily and you
know missing that sort of communication
between people you love and care about
you know like oh just I think I'm gonna
miss my phone most you know obviously my
99 year old grandmother just like has no
idea like she thinks I'm going to jail
probably she's like what did you do you
know and you know some of the middle
range relatives I think are just more
like don't understand like well why
would you want to do that you know like
why would you want to put yourself in a
potentially painful disturbing you know
possibly unpleasant situation like why
would you want to do that yeah I'm
feeling I'm feeling anxious about it but
also you know excited to sort of have a
learning experience for myself and to
share it with you know the tweets and
the people out there who are good watch
the show I think it'll be um you know
once in a lifetime experience finger
secure just kidding oh you know so i
looked at the calendar I have you know
eight days in my mind and I just I like
to have goals I don't see myself
stopping I I just don't I see myself
lasting the whole time definitely a just
I have to
Oh around sanity